quick warning please don't try this at
home thank you
so there was a pretty big announcement
the other week we are about to get a
lord of the rings
anime i saw that and i was so excited i
went back and i started re-watching all
of the original movies and i got to the
second movie
where the urukai just kidnapped two of
the hobbits and then the three other
dudes decided to just chase after them
and the thing is that
they didn't walk okay they didn't ride
horses they just straight up
sprinted like the entire time i sat
through a whole minute of just running
b-roll of them sprinting over
mountains until gimli says that they've
been at it for three days
like why is no one talking about this
they're wearing this armor
how is that even possible apparently
they ran a total of 135 miles
well the first thing is they didn't run
it straight it is over the course of
three days but they did rest every night
in the books
the movies though they're full on
running i know people have run
ultra marathons people have run 100
miles but usually when they do that
they are doing it in the best running
gear possible they're in
aerodynamics tight closed and they've
trained for it a lot to just go
from a battle to a full run is not
something
any normal person could do i know that
gimli was wearing full-on male armor i
think the other two didn't really wear
armor even when they do wear armor
they never wear helmets is that an
actual practical choice
obviously there's like a trade-off when
you're wearing armor it's heavy it's
cumbersome
if you're wearing a helmet it restricts
your field of view it makes it kind of
difficult to
navigate and it makes it difficult to do
anything and it makes it way more
difficult a lot slower to
like use a sword in i will be very
impressed to see if you can
manage to run in all that and now i
gotta just
see for myself how does armor really
affect your physical abilities you would
think that armor is hard to find but
amazon is a thing now so there you go
right off the bat you can see that it's
full of holes it won't block the sun
and it's like 90 plus degrees outside so
i'm gonna wear this long compression
gear underneath and then i couldn't put
on the armor without almost ripping out
my hair
so i got this cooling skull cap so now
i'm basically frozone let's do a quick
weigh-in just to see what we're dealing
with i'll go without the armor and then
with it and then just subtract this is
about 20 pounds total which doesn't
sound too bad
but it feels so much worse than that
when i'm moving but i feel like a badly
customized
human in an elder scrolls game so i'm
going to take this through a full body
strength training split
that's a mouthful over the next few days
and do some cardio too just to simulate
the kind of fatigue that the characters
probably went through and then at the
end i'm going to run a 5k while wearing
this
armor and we'll see what happens all
right we're starting with lower body i
put on this medieval
leather belt to hold the chains a bit
and give a little back support
really just looks cool deadlifts have
been around since ancient grease
pretty straight forward pick thing up
put it down immediately
i get now why they went without helmets
sometimes all right the shirt
felt pretty bad but the head thing was
[ __ ] terrible
i was jerking my head up against the
weight which completely throws off the
lift
your head's pretty far from your center
of gravity so every time i tilted my
head at all
it felt like the koi was dragging me to
the floor now the weight didn't feel too
weird during the squats because you stay
pretty upright
but i realize that chains aren't fabric
so they don't stretch
so at the bottom of the squat or any
athletic movement they kind of just
lock up and you get stuck there
especially around the hips the fatigue
really hit me during the lunges
i was almost falling over and i was out
of breath but i powered through to my
next rest
and then it really hit me there are no
rests
during combat like in a battle there are
no rounds you have to keep going until
one side's completely wiped out and if
you think about how large these armies
were in the movies
they were probably at it for a really
long time and high intensity
the entire time i finished up with some
one leg romanian deadlifts and some
standing calf raises
it was like impossible to balance with
the armor on but i made it through and
lift to fight another day
today we're doing push day going on a
hike and then testing out a run
at one point in the movie gimli
literally bench pressed two wargs and an
orc at the same time so i guess you
gotta train for that then you gotta
build those delts so you can boost
people up under walls
ledges or giant elephant things these
felt okay but i couldn't really lock out
at the top
dips honestly i give this a 10 out of
10. it was a really smooth distribution
of weight but it was super hard
especially for three sets
then i found out that lying down is
terrible because it feels like something
sitting on you and pinning you down
even worse if something gets around your
neck so if you trip me during a battle
i'll look like this
[Laughter]
we're gonna finish off with some lateral
raises and then take this bad boy out
for a spin
i'm gonna hike because i haven't
unlocked fast travel yet honestly this
was super enjoyable
it felt as cool as it looks during
movies only
problem is that past 20 to 30 minutes in
i would not be able to hold a
conversation
so to me the dialogue in movies is
easily the least believable part
next i tried running and right away i
found out that
chains bounce up and down so it's
actually a lot worse than just carrying
20 pounds of weight
the actual force is greater than that
every time you push off and
land on each leg my lower body still
felt destroyed from yesterday so i
called it quits after about a mile or so
but i am getting the hang of this armor
and hopefully i can pull off a full run
tomorrow
day three is a pull workout and the 5k
if for some reason i'm hanging off the
ledge in armor it's pretty much game
over i hit failure right on the first
set and after three failed sets i tried
switching up the grip
i got in one full set and then just
failed the next one
then we're doing rows you know for those
times where you stand over a fallen
teammate
say something corny and then pull them
back up we'll do some face pulls because
people in movies have good posture and
then we'll finish off with some bicep
curl variations
uh no purpose just aesthetics i took a
little break
and now we do the run i'm aiming for a
5k here and i made it about a block away
and i realized i could not deal with
those chains around the neck so i strap
them down with this neck gaiter
and the whole thing looks even cooler
now i'm not really a serious
trained runner so i realized like half a
mile to a mountain
probably shouldn't just wing it for a
video i was really feeling it in my
shins my knees and my feet
so i took a lot of walking breaks and
got to the halfway point about 30
minutes in and i was like huh
i'm still alive that's great so i
thought i'd just keep running
i was running at a bunch of different
paces but i think i averaged at like 10
and a half minutes per mile
and i looked it up on mine afterwards
apparently it's not that great but you
know what
you try it with armor i finally took a
walking break and found out
it's only been two minutes like what at
some point i decided
you know the pain's not getting that
much worse i broke through some kind of
mental wall
i got over the whole armor thing and i
made it to 5k in just under 48 minutes i
was so
dead i couldn't even pull the chainmail
up over my head to get it off
i had to go into this puppy dog pose i
actually surprised myself
like all those things are actually
doable in armor
it's just miserable it actually messed
up my sleep quality at night and
everything from my hips downward just
turned into jello but i guess that's
because i'm at like an
average person's level of fitness i
guess if you do train in the armor or
you're a runner
you'll probably do a lot better but even
still running an armor is so much more
taxing that
i guess if you were in an army and you
had to charge at another army
other things being equal you're probably
going to lose but yeah that's just my
hypothesis
maybe we'll test that in another video
let me know what you think down in the
comments
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next time
you